In kinematics, if we
know acceleration,
which we generally can get
from Newton's second law,
then we'd like to
integrate the acceleration
to get velocity and position.
How does that work
for circular motion?
Well, when you think
about circular motion
and you think about the
tangential direction,
then that, in some sense,
is a one-dimensional motion.
And so what we'll see is that
the tangential description
of this motion can be integrated
to get the tangential velocity
and position, just
in a similar way
that we did with
linear motion, where
if we were given
the acceleration,
we integrated
velocity and position.
So let's look at a
particular example.
Suppose we're given that
the tangential component
of the acceleration is given
by some simple polynomial, A
minus Bt.
Now, in this case,
the acceleration
is certainly non-constant.
What we'd like to
do-- remember, this
is equal to rd squared
theta dt squared.
So if we integrate the
tangential component
of the acceleration
with some variable
from t prime going from
some initial value, which
we can call 0, to
some final value,
then that will
give us the change
in the tangential velocity.
So for this case,
V theta of t is
equal to V theta t0 plus the
integral of A minus B t prime
d t prime.
Now, we needed an integration
variable because recall
that our functional
dependence is the upper limit
of the integral.
We saw that in
one-dimensional kinematics.
So we're going from some
t0 0 to some prime t prime.
Well, this integral
is now-- we'll
write this V theta 0, where,
again, t0 we're calling 0.
And when we do this integral,
A minus B t prime and d
t prime-- that's an integral
from 0 to t prime equals t.
t prime equals 0.
This integral is not hard to do.
We get A of t minus
1/2 B of t squared.
And there's that
constant initial term.
And so the velocity at time
t of the tangential component
of the velocity is given
by that expression.
In exactly the same fashion,
the angle-- how much angle
does this go through?
Well, we have to
be careful there.
So if we want to do
the arc length, s of t,
we have to multiply the
angle by the radius.
And that is just the integral
of the tangential component
of the velocity from t prime
equal 0 to time t prime t.
And so in this example, we
have a slightly complicated
integral, V0 d t prime, 0 to t.
I'm going to drop--
well, I'll write it
in-- t prime plus the
integrals A t prime minus 1/2
B t prime squared.
I didn't need to split this up.
But I'm splitting it up, anyway.
And I have really one,
two, three integrals to do.
And what I get is V
theta 0 t-- the result
of the first integral.
The result of the second
interval is 1/2 At squared.
And the result of
the third integral
is minus 1/6 B t cubed.
And that gives me this.
I have to be a little
careful on this side.
It's how much has the arc length
changed as we go from time 0
to time t.
So that's the change
in arc length.
And that's a typical
example of where we're
given tangential acceleration.
We integrate it to get
the tangential velocity.
And then when we integrate
the tangential velocity,
we're getting the change in
arc length around the circle.